this is a business that's very important
to remember you will get
hired to do what you show you can do
i believe you originally set out to be a
director
i wouldn't say i set out to be a
director you know when i was
first interested in
making films
you know i
spent many years studying fine art fine
art was my passion and it still is my
passion because to me this is fine art
in a different medium
but when i originally transitioned into
thinking i might want to do it i as as a
visual artist who is the principal
author i thought well i would want to be
the auteur hence the director and that
made sense to me
and so all through college that was sort
of what i was thinking and then i got
out and my first feature film that i
worked on um
i got on set and you know i was hustling
i did all kinds of things over the
period of time this is the job i was
telling you about where i was
volunteering and i was working with
professionals
and the first thing they threw at me
because you know i was a musician i did
a lot of recording so i knew sound so
they had me be the boom operator
and then the sound guy had days he
couldn't show up because again we're all
volunteering and and that's another
thing about volunteering because of the
attrition you step up pretty quickly so
he trained me how to record sound so i'm
recording sound and you know i learned
grip work and um oh the first ac can't
show up brad you want to pull focus you
know can you run a camera i mean i went
from being the little guy to you know
being the guy that you know a couple of
times it was me and the director and a
wind-up bolex and we were the crew
so you know that was that was kind of
the thing but when i was on that job and
i was watching that director who's a
friend of this day and i really respect
this guy
but
everybody was hitting on him everybody
on set wanted a piece of him you know um
you know
understandably uh you know the actors
wanted his time and the
wardrobe people and the producer and the
location people and it's just like
you know okay and then over here is the
dp now this person has the magic box and
they get to look through the magic box
and make the pretty pictures they get
the lights the toys and i'm thinking now
that that looks like fun
and um
the funny thing to me is is that was
that was the that was the instinct in
that moment
years later looking at it retroactively
you know i have a lot of interest in
science just a huge science geek i love
history and i love music and of course
visual art
and i was reflecting and i realized that
all of those disciplines
converge in cinematography
you know you've got the art obviously
you've got the science in terms of the
technology the physics um you know uh
optics things like that you've got
history because you understand you know
the way that that a film was shot in the
20s versus the 40s you understand um you
know the history of cameras and film
grain and digital um because it all
plays in and informs your creative
choices you know if i want something
with a little bit of a retro look i have
to understand that history plus the
industry's got a fascinating history um
and then as in terms of music i've done
a lot of camera operating and i've come
to find that there are rhythms
even if you're even if you aren't aware
of that nobody's tapping out a drum but
in a scene
in my head i've got a metronome and i'm
like this person
that person this person speaks they grab
the glass and i find there's a rhythm
and
to reinforce this i'll tell you an
interesting story about how i cut my
montages
most people find a piece of music
cut to the beats of the music i never do
that to me it feels artificial it feels
forced
i will cut to the rhythms of the visuals
and then i will find music that fits
those and the thing that is just
profound to me time and again is you
find the right song and it just drops
into place and all those beats hit um
and sometimes you maybe there's a little
nipper tuck here you know sometimes i
might cut the music and fiddle with it a
little bit but and sometimes the rhythm
changes you know we're all splicing a
different piece of music but literally
all the feature montages on my website
were done that way none of them were cut
to music so so just the rhythm of it and
so all of those things converging it
just made me realize
i'm not i'm not a spiritual person but
but things like that are kind of
profound it's at least magical you know
when the universe conspires
or whatever it is you know even though i
don't embrace anything i don't exclude
anything maybe there is something really
cool out there that put me here um
but uh
yeah that was that was kind of the thing
is that uh you know i i made that
decision i had that impulse on that
first set and then looking back
i was just overwhelmed by by
all the affirmation of why that had been
the right decision
when did you realize that being a
filmmaker in houston texas wasn't the
place for you at that time and then what
happened when you moved here to los
angeles it's a good question so so
obviously i started my career in the
film industry in houston and i had you
know people i worked with who are
mentors and friends and i still do i've
been back i've worked there again
i'm a big supporter of houston and of
texas
i'm an advocate of the filmmaking
community there and i want to see it do
well
my i have a lot of mentees there to this
day
and i support the community i just
actually was invited to become a board
member for southwest
alternative media project in houston
which is a film advocacy and education
group that's been around since the 70s
so i'm really honored and i feel that
i'm still
a part of that community
but uh what i did realize at the time
was you know because i i knew i wanted
to be a cinematographer there wasn't any
question i've always known what i wanted
to be even when i was a little kid i
knew i wanted to be a garbage man now i
didn't stay wanting to be a garbage man
then i wanted to be an astronaut
but i've never been one of those people
who didn't know so i you know even
though that has swapped out and and so i
knew at that time and i thought about it
and there were some really good
cinematographers in in town and still
are
and i thought
you know in order for me to get a shot
you know
these guys are going to have to retire
or there's going to have to be more work
and it really became evident to me that
it was a little bit of a closed
ecosystem it was a small market
and i thought
you know
i realized what a sacrifice it was going
to be i realized in terms of my free
time in terms of you know the
volunteering i would have to do to you
know earn my stripes and build my
network and learn my skills um
just in terms of being a freelancer and
not having regular work um
the uncertainty
you know all of those things and i
realized okay i'm taking a big risk and
that sort of percolated in my brain
and the funny thing is i never made a
calculated decision to leave
one day i walked home i didn't walk on
my drove home and i walked into the
house because yeah i was living with my
parents at 25 because
why not you know i was a filmmaker they
were
nice people i loved them and i was happy
to be there
and you know for practical reasons i'm
like you know i i have no need for that
expense
and i'm content so i stayed there and i
so i walked home i didn't walk home i
keep saying that i drove home and i was
walking into the house
and i and i just i had this
lark that i was just gonna go provoke my
parents i was just gonna tell them that
i was moving to l.a just to get a rise
out of them and i figured they would
talk me out of it and and uh so i walked
in
and um you know there had there had been
no prelude to this it had never been
discussed before and i walked in and i
said i've decided to move to los angeles
and they said that's wonderful we
completely support you we think that's
just such a smart decision and and in
that moment i thought oh i've
committed myself i have to follow
through now
um because again i you know but the
funny thing is you know just like i say
you know maybe sometimes the universe
guides you because maybe it was just
like you know i got pushed
to where i needed to be in that moment
because again it wasn't a conscious
thing
um
but
i made plans with a camera assistant
friend of mine you know to to go out and
i'd already had some friends out here um
i had some filmmaker friends and i
thought okay well i'll go and i'll cast
my lot with those people you know none
of them were established they were all
you know wanting to be filmmakers
and i had this one friend who said well
i could come crash on her floor
um and so you know my friend and i made
plans that we would leave in a month
and um started thinking about it like
why are we waiting a month and i was
like let's just go so
two weeks in
we left so we got there and um you know
living living like
thieves on the on the floor
and um
this could be a long story but i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna fast forward does it
involve the whiskey of go go sorry
why do i feel like some of that's coming
in no well we were i was in venice it
was beautiful my friend lived in a
townhouse involved okay so but anyway i
got there and i had a lot of delusions i
really did i thought you know um um oh
and the the other reason that that it
made sense to me at the time was that
you know
instead of making all these sacrifices
for this limited market if i'm going to
pay this price
i'm going to go where the sky is the
limit you know that was the logic that
reinforced that decision
so i get out here and i just i made so
many bad assumptions about how i was
going to be welcomed with open arms and
get business and get work and you know
probably 30 000 other people had that
same idea you know and
so i spent i spent some years kind of
aimlessly and you know to make a living
i was doing temp work in offices i was
doing the freebies at the time they had
this publication called dramalog which
is kind of like you know the
what craigslist is today a lot of it was
student films but i'm like you know i'm
building a reel i still had a few things
i'd shot in used it but i didn't have
much of a reel so you know i just needed
more footage and you know even if i'm
working for free somebody else is paying
for the film and the locations and the
camera
um
so i did that for a while um and it was
really dodgy and and at one point i had
this epiphany and i thought you know
all the people i know are at the same
level i am you know we we kind of
got into this and said you know all for
one and one for all we're all going to
be filmmakers
the problem with that is i realized that
if i want to make a living at this i
have to work with people who do it for a
living you know
and that was a very
transformational realization for me and
when i did that that's when i started
moving forward and i started you know
applying to companies like concord new
horizons one of my really good buddies
out here um
worked for them and uh he was in the
marketing department but you know he
gave me names and and pointed me in the
right direction and and that's just kind
of how it got started and you know
from there it took a couple of years and
then i shot some movies for those guys
um you know did some more indies
a young fellow who i mentored in houston
um ended up blowing up as a huge music
video director and you know through a
set of circumstances we ended up working
together and that jumped me up some
levels um and then when music videos
kind of subsided i transitioned over you
know the big budgets kind of went away i
transitioned over to commercials and um
and then those kind of uh evaporated and
and now i'm doing narrative again
so you probably cut big chunks of that
out no no i love i love the story so
that that's interesting so you're here
in la and you're you're enjoying time
with friends but you looked around and
said what is going to set me apart from
these people and that was that
realization knowing that you were
working with other people that
this was paying their mortgage this was
putting their kids in school
and knowing that they were going to take
it very seriously i don't know i'm
paraphrasing but well i don't know i
think that the whole
set yourself apart realization came a
bit later all i realized was that i was
working with wannabes i was a wannabe my
peers were one of these you know but
wanna be is if it's it's like it's like
entropy you know you're in a vacuum and
and nobody in there has the capacity to
advance you unless you get lucky it's
like the lottery you know do you you
know win a festival award and even then
what does that matter you know so um
this is a business that's very important
to remember you will get
hired to do what you show you can do
so if all you do is freebie low budget
stuff that's what you're going to get
brought on for if all you do is
volunteer stuff you know that may be
what you get stuck in if all you do is
commercials it's going to be hard to get
a feature film and even if you do
commercials like me and you got a broad
variety of stuff if somebody wants a car
commercial they want the car person they
want the one with you know 10 10 car
spots or you know the beauty person i
can do all of those things you know and
i have and i can show them but i don't
have the preponderance and and so that
was the thing that that you know just
going back to my early my first
experience with that phenomenon was that
i was working with with one of these
people i liked people who were talented
but nobody was in a position to jump me
up to a salaried position and i had to
break outside of that
paradigm you know just end the entropy
go to a completely different model
and that model was to find the people
who were getting paid to do the work and
work with them
and that was really probably one of my
very first significant
realizations of of
you know learning the dynamics in this
industry
and we basically are all wannabes when
we start out at something so
i'm still a wannabe you know there's
still things i want to do i don't say
that that term maliciously at all it's
just you know we were powerless we had
no connections and nobody was giving us
money so you know it's not a judgment
it's just that was the fact